we saw something there
with the download festival and you you
were going over in england
to play the download festival and then
you had like some
crazy like medical condition when you
were bleeding the platelets
that was called itp i got that [ __ ] from
taking an
antibiotic called cath-lex that [ __ ]
it at the time they're like no no no
it's not catholics but if you go on our
website now you'll see it on the fine
print
may in rare cases cause idp so i took
this stuff
a doctor gave me and i was on the
antibiotic and all of a sudden i started
going to i went to europe to go on tour
and started seeing bruises pop up on my
body well what the [ __ ] i'm so i'm
whatever okay i got bruises i go crazy
on stage it's fine
next thing i know i go i think it was a
show in germany and i go to go to the
bathroom and i start pouring blood out
of my ass it's like
pouring out of my ass so i'm like holy
[ __ ] so of course i'm like nothing's
wrong with me i go play a show
i go back after that pouring blood i
call a doctor i'm like what the flying
[ __ ] is going on
once you go to the doctor get on this
boat we were going from germany to
london so i got on a boat i slept
went on the boat i got there went to the
doctor and he started
examining me and he's like oh this is
[ __ ] horrible bro
he put a speculum in my ass bro okay
like i'm like he's on this is gonna be
uncomfortable i'm sorry but i gotta do
this so he sticks his stuff boom in his
ass and he looks up and goes yep you're
bleeding
and i'm like [ __ ] i could have
told you that
just ask next time
the speculum is like the duck bill kind
of thing right right so you can
ask oh my god what the [ __ ] i'm a
[ __ ] european
oh my god yeah and he went here he makes
you go back to the hotel
and he goes i'll call you let you know
what's going on and he calls me a little
later he goes
go directly to the hospital don't bump
anything
get there now so i'm freaking the [ __ ]
out i'm like what you said your platelet
counts five you have no platelets and
those are basically what keep your blood
in your veins
basically the what your blood is so
i go there they they take tests my
platelet counts five
they're all tripping out they give me a
bone marrow test which
was hell um and then they put me on
steroids how does a bone marrow test
work
they nail a [ __ ] spike into your hip
and suck the bone marrow out wow that
was horrible but anyways
they started putting they put me on this
they said you have this thing called itp
your
immune system is killing your platelets
i'm like oh this is great
so they get my platelet count up to over
a hundred i was there
in the hospital for three or four days
and then i fly back
home and it took a year for it to
normalize but
every so often my platelet account would
go up it would be good it would be good
it'd be good and once i got off the
medicine
it normalized so i don't have it anymore
but it was scary because i
i could have let out geez maybe in my
head and doing those shows
i could have [ __ ] stroked out so
easily what's a normal platelet click
count
anywhere above 100 and what is it
180 and above
uh to 880 to like 400.
yeah way more than five yeah the thing
we saw
said that you were bleeding out of your
gums like your gums were just pouring
blood
um my gums would bleed um anything if i
pinched myself like this just a little
pinch
a bruise that come up there's no they
help line the walls of your
of your veins i guess they told me and
you just bleed it's crazy so i was just
like
taking it easy and letting the music let
the medicine work and it worked good it
took me a year to get back to normal but
did you have to cancel it
what did you have to cancel a bunch of
dates um yeah we had to cancel the tour
i had to fly back and find out what was
going on
and yeah that was scary um but
it got better and better as time went on
and i won't ever take that stuff again
yeah dude